okay in a much awaited decision the
Supreme Court just moments ago decided
72 that Donald Trump cannot ignore a
subpoena of his financial records sought
by New York prosecutors and the wording
that I selected to tell you that is not
trivial and I'm going to explain it to
you momentarily so zoomed out this is a
big legal defeat for Donald Trump at the
same time his lawyer is calling it a
victory in that he is saying now they
can fight this out at a lower court and
yet Donald Trump is also Simon
simultaneously going absolutely crazy on
Twitter and we're going to walk through
all of it so let's start with the
decision itself there's some confusion
because there were actually two
decisions made here and also the
decision is about whether this now goes
back to a lower court to be fought so
what the Supreme Court said today is
that the path is legally cleared for
prosecutors to seek Donald Trump's
financial records at the lower court
level a lower court previously found
that Donald Trump is not immune from
responding to subpoenas because he is
President of the United States that's
really the big decision here because for
a while Donald Trump and his lawyers and
others have argued it's not just that
Trump is immune from indictment Donald
Trump is immune from investigation by
virtue of being President of the United
States and therefore he doesn't even
have to respond to a subpoena for his
financial records what the court found
in a 7 to 2 decision is that Trump is
not immune from investigation and that's
actually a really big deal however this
now means that it goes back to a lower
court and what Trump's lawyer is saying
is okay well I mean you know framing it
as positively as possible now we go back
to the lower court to keep working to
fight these records from being provided
on other grounds and of course prevent
them from going public and the the
second part of the Supreme Court
decision Congress was also seeking
Trump's financial records for now the
Supreme Court has said prosecutors can
seek Trump's records you've got to
figure it out but Congress for now is
not going to trump is not going to be
compelled to provide financial records
to Congress so this is I mean listen if
you want me to - just give you the
highlight we're not going to see Trump's
taxes before the election right we have
four months until the election what has
been decided is that on principle Trump
can't just ignore the subpoena from
prosecutors but now it's going to be
fought at the lower court if indeed
Trump has to provide his financial
records it's not going to be done public
it will have to be kept quiet at least
and certainly beyond the November
election so if your idea was based on
this decision we might see Trump's taxes
before November not going to happen now
Trump is going crazy on Twitter he
immediately started tweeting
uncontrollably as soon as this decision
went public and I'm gonna go through
some of those tweets Trump starting with
quote the Supreme Court sends case back
to lower court arguments to continue
this is all a political prosecution I
won the Moller witch-hunt that's the one
that said it couldn't clear Trump on
obstruction I won the Malheur witch-hunt
and others and now I have to keep
fighting in a politically corrupt New
York not fair to this presidency or
administration he's the victim he's the
most powerful person in the world maybe
and yet he's the victim everybody is
unfair to him he just he q it's all just
stacked against him from continuing with
another tweet saying quote courts in the
past have given broad deference but not
to me again he's the victim he's being
singled out the courts are singling him
everybody is just singling him out poor
Trump and then a three tweet rant where
Trump said quote we have a totally
corrupt previous administration
including a president and vice president
who spied on my campaign and got kite I
guess he meant caught I got kite and
nothing happens to them this crime was
taking place even before
everyone knows it and he had all her
frozen stiff with fear one against one
all against the federal government and
the Democrats send everything to
politically corrupt in New York I'm
struggling to parse the grammar which is
falling apart with everyone leaving to
give it a second third and fourth try
now the Supreme Court gives a delay
ruling that they would never have given
for another president this is about all
caps prosecutorial misconduct we catch
the other side spying on my campaign the
biggest political crime and scandal in
US history and nothing happens but
despite this I have done more than any
president in history in first three and
a half years there might be are there
six lies there are could might there
even be seven lies or distort it's it's
crazy what is going on and again if his
lawyer considers this a victory why is
Trump going so crazy but the important
takeaway is Trump is not immune from
investigation that's good it's a good
thing the court has clarified that but
we are not going to see Donald Trump's
taxes before November and we all need to
accept that that is the case the good
news is we don't need to see Trump's
taxes to know he has to be removed
whether we see Trump's taxes or not we
know that Trump has to be removed in
November so this isn't going to
complicate voting for me if you
understand what I'm saying real quick I
want to tell you about our sponsor magic
spoon who have done something awesome
they've taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals that we know we
shouldn't eat any more and turn them
into something you can actually feel
good about eating as an adult there's
four flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry they taste great they're
crunchy they're sweet like you would
expect this type of cereal to be but
it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one Bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain
free soy free once our team tried magic
spoon for the first time we actually
ended up emailing magic spoon back and
saying can you send us more boxes send
more samples they've been a big hit with
David Pakman show staffers and magic
spoon knows how delicious their cereal
is because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked and you'll get free shipping when
you go to magic spoon dot-com slash
Pakman and use the code Pakman that's PA
hey ma n